[JOHN] Hi, there. This is John Green.
[HANK] And I'm Hank Green,
and we are the Vlogbrothers on YouTube.
[JOHN] And we are making this video
a Frequently Asked Questions video
for the purposes of answering some questions
that are frequently asked.
[HANK] People are often confused.
Like, for example, what is a Nerdfighter?
[JOHN] A Nerdfighter is a person who,
instead of being made out of, like,
bones and skin and tissue,
is made entirely of awesome.
[HANK] So what you're saying is that
Nerdfighters don't fight nerds?
[JOHN] No, we're clearly... pro-nerd.
[HANK] Nerdfighter is basically just
the community that sprung up around our videos,
and, basically, we just get together
and try to do awesome things
and have a good time
and fight against World Suck.
[JOHN] What's World Suck?
[HANK] World Suck is kind of exactly
what World Suck sounds like.
It's hard to quantify exactly, but, you know,
it's, like, the amount
of suck in the world.
[JOHN] One of the questions
we get asked the most is:
"Do you guys have real jobs?"
[HANK] Yes!
[JOHN] Well, I mean, it depends on how you
define "real".
Hank runs the environmental technology website
EcoGeek.
[HANK] John Green is an award-winning author.
He has written books such as Looking For Alaska,
An Abundance of Katherines, and Paper Towns,
and he's won many awards including
the Edgar Award and the,
the Printz Award.
[HANK] Why don't you blink?
[JOHN] I don't blink because I'm focusing
when I'm in front of the camera.
I do blink in real life.
That's why I still have eyes.
And, also, it's sort of a tribute to the original
video blogger,
our hero,
zefrank.
[JOHN] So, Hank, what's DFTBA?
[HANK] DFTBA is an acronym.
[JOHN] No, it isn't!
It is not an acronym.
Acronyms are pronounceable. It is an initialism.
[HANK trying to pronounce DFTBA] Dfft-tpuh...
[JOHN] Dfft-buh.
[BOTH laugh]
[HANK] Okay. It's an initialism
that stands for
Don't Forget To Be Awesome.
[JOHN] Am I too young...
[HANK] ...old...
[JOHN] ...fat...
[HANK] ...skinny...
[JOHN] ...weird...
[HANK] ...cool...
[JOHN] ...nerdy...
[HANK] ...handsome...
[JOHN] ...tall...
[HANK] ...dead...
[BOTH] ...to be a Nerdfighter?
[JOHN] No!
If you wanna be a Nerdfighter,
you ARE a Nerdfighter!
[HANK] Nerdfighter dictionary time!
[JOHN] Lightning round.
[HANK] Puppy-sized elephants.
[JOHN] We asked natural selection
to make us puppy-sized elephants,
because they would have
the evolutionary advantage
of being adorable, and we are waiting for
that to happen.
[JOHN] Stuff on heads?
[HANK] Yeah, if you put stuff on your head,
it makes you feel better about life.
[JOHN] Nerdfighter gatherings?
[HANK] Is when Nerdfighters get together.
Sometimes we're there, sometimes we're not.
[JOHN] French the llama?
[HANK] French the llama is something that
John is trying to make into a thing,
in which people say [for example],
"French the llama, that whale is big",
but it's not gonna work.
[JOHN] Oh, it's gonna happen!
I'm gonna make french the llama happen!
[HANK] Puff levels?
[JOHN] Uh, my puff level is the level of puff
in my hair,
which gets higher as I get more stressed out.
[HANK] Decepticon?
[JOHN] Is the opposite of a Nerdfighter.
[JOHN] Giant squid of anger?
[HANK] Is basically like a YouTube troll.
[Makes angry squid noises]
[JOHN] Tiny chicken disease?
[HANK] Is a disease that happens when
there's tiny chickens in your head and they lay eggs and all of it gooes out of your nose.
It's actually...
[JOHN] It's a common cold.
[HANK] Yeah.
[JOHN] Secret siblings?
[HANK] Secret siblings are anyone who makes
video responses down here to our videos.
[JOHN] Down here, in my pants.
[HANK] In your pants?
[JOHN] "In your pants" is a phenomenon
discovered by Maureen Johnson.
If you add "in your pants" to the end of book titles,
those book titles become much funnier.
"The Sun Also Rises... In Your Pants"
[HANK] "A Spot of Bother... In Your Pants"
[JOHN] Notsome?
[HANK] Notsome is the opposite of awesome.
See also Fail Puppy and the Fail Boat.
[HANK] The Yeti?
[JOHN] Is my wife. The Katherine...
[HANK] ...is my wife.
[JOHN] Oh, and this...
[HANK] Ah... is the Nerdfighter gang sign.
So, if you see somebody doing this,
you know not to shoot them.
[JOHN] We have created a playlist of twenty
Vlogbrothers videos
that you can watch
that will give you a broader sense of
what's going on in Nerdfighteria, in case
you're new.
[HANK] And if you have any friends
that are a little bit confused about why
you're watching two nerds make videos
about Star Wars
and giraffe love and
making the world a better place
through video...
[JOHN] Those, those are three
interconnected ideas.
[HANK laughs]
[HANK] ...then you can send them to this video
right here
so that they can get a little bit of a debrief
before plunging in to the rest of our... stuff.
[JOHN] Now, the playlist is on the screen
and we gotta do like a little playlist song.
[BOTH singing] Woo!
[HANK] Playlist song, playlist song!
Bwoo-bwoo-bwoo!
Playlist song, playlist song!
Boop-bwoo bwoo-bwoo!
[JOHN speaking] Now, did you just write that?
Because that's really good.
That's brilliant.
Did you, like, did you come up with that
off the top of your head like that?
[HANK singing] Bwoo!
[BOTH laugh]
[HANK] It's like Mario swimming.
[Singing] Bwoo-bwoo-bwoo!
[JOHN] Nerdfighteria, thanks for being awesome
and thanks for all the support you've given us
as we continue into our fourth year
of making videos.
Best wishes!
[HANK] DFTBA!